and we are going to begin with the
latest Democratic presidential debate
which put the party's policy divide
front and center in in front of the
entire nation centrist candidates
repeatedly argued last night that
proposals from left-wing Democrats go
too far and play into Republicans hands
candidates Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders took turns defending their plans
for everything from health care to
immigration ed O'Keefe is in Detroit
where he covered the debate Ed Wood
stood out to you well Anthony look
voters had said to us they wanted
substance and last night they got it
conversations about health care
immigration gun control and how to pay
for college just because it was
substantive though doesn't mean it
didn't get testy this is an example of
wishlist economics you can't just spring
a plan on the world I expect it to
succeed moderate Democrats desperate for
attention came out swinging early
knowing this might be their only chance
to challenge the liberal views of
senators Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren win when we run on real solutions
not impossible promises when we run on
things that are workable not fairy tale
economics but the two senators
anticipated the attacks and hit back you
know I don't understand why anybody does
to all the trouble of running for
president of the United States just to
talk about what we really can't do and
shouldn't fight for Medicare for all is
comprehensive it covers all health care
needs for senior citizens it will
finally include dental care hearing aids
and eyeglasses but you don't second of
all I wrote the damn bill why do we got
to be the party of taking something away
running on telling half the country that
your health insurance is illegal it says
it right in the bill let's be clear
about this we are the Democrats we are
not about trying to take away health
care from anyone that's what the
Republicans are
the other Democrats on stage also
stopped short of Sanders and Warren's
calls for decriminalization of border
crossers if you want to come into the
country you should at least ring the
doorbell we got a hundred thousand
people showing up the border right now
if we decriminalize entry if we get
health care to everyone
we'll have multiples of that and
continue to debate whether the
government should be paying college
tuition my problem with some of these
plans is they literally would pay for
wealthy kids for wall street kids to go
to college we can have debt free college
for low and middle income students by
expanding Pell grants and compelling
states to pick up more of the burden the
best thing you could do to stimulate the
US economy is to get rid of this debt
but all agreed on the need to defeat
President Trump Trump is a pathological
liar I tell the truth ultimately we have
to beat Donald Trump anyone on this
stage tonight or tomorrow night would be
a far better president so folks we're
calling last night the motown showdown
maybe today we call tonight's debate the
Detroit do-over former Vice President
Joe Biden will be standing alongside
California senator Kamala Harris who
surprised him at the last debate by
going after his record on civil rights
he says he won't be polite if one of his
competitors comes at him Harris says
she'll merely call out differences when
needed we'll see what happens
Anthony yes we will and thank you very
much